on this issue if the 14
million unserved rural americans and yes
unserved they have nothing
think about the progress we could have
made if these 14
million unserved americans
had taken precedent
in the minds and in the agenda
of our friends across the aisle
it would have been great to focus on
that and speaking of
infrastructure perhaps we could have
focused
more energy on giving the needed
authority to our local officials
so that they can fix crumbling roads and
bridges
and getting regulations out of their way
so they can go to work helping people
get to work helping children get back to
school and
certainly i know a few officials in
memphis
who would love to see us start thinking
long
term about practical infrastructure
support
that doesn't include the green new deal
fantasies that are favored by this white
house
the american people have noticed this
lack of focus and this free
wheeling attitude when it comes to
spending
taxpayers money when they look around
they see
real need there are businesses and
families that are still struggling
to pull themselves out of the ashes of
the pandemic
policies that are favored by the
democrats
would be policies that would bankrupt
their businesses that would drive up the
debt
that would cause massive inflation
and tennesseans know these policies
are not going to help them what it does
do
is to frustrate them neither will the
democrats continued failure
to manage president biden's border
crisis
in april customs and border protection
apprehended 178 000 people
attempting to illegally cross
our border 14 000
of these were unaccompanied alien
children
it's a record year for drug runners for
the cartels
for bootleggers for human traffickers
for sex traffickers we caught the
department of health and human services
actually finishing the work of the
cartels trafficking many of those
unaccompanied minors through the
chattanooga airport without the
knowledge
or the involvement of local officials
meanwhile my democratic colleagues are
treating this humanitarian crisis
as if it's nothing more than a logistics
challenge
but perhaps if we had spent more time on
this
in the past month we could have
convinced them
that until they get this crisis under
control
they have to admit in this country right
now
every town is a border town every state
a border state just ask your local law
enforcement
they will tell you
perhaps they didn't want to put the time
there because
they've been busy putting a show on for
the cameras and their friends on the
left tennesseans
noticed what went on here this month
they're not happy about it
they've been reaching out they don't
have the luxury
of playing political games they don't
have the spare
resources to gamble on woke
politics they're trying to keep the
doors
of their businesses and their churches
and their schools and their factories
open
we did a lot of talking this month but
the
friends on the left chose not to take
action to solve
problems i would encourage them to do a
little soul-searching
over the next couple of weeks and
address the agenda that the american
people
would seek to have addressed i yield the
floor
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
cloture motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
to hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on the nomination of executive
calendar number 172
deborah l boardman of maryland to the
united states district judge
for the district of maryland 17 senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived
the question is is this is it the sense
of the senate
that debate on the nomination of deborah
l boardman of maryland
to be the united states district judge
for the district of maryland
shall be brought to a close the yeas and
nays are mandatory under the rule and
the clerk will call the role
ms baldwin
foreign
mr barrasso
mr bennett
this is blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blunt
mr booker
mr boseman
mr brawn
[Music]
mr brown
mr burr
mr camwell this is cappuccio
mr cardin
[Music]
mr carper mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins mr coons
mr cornyn
ms cortes masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crabow
mr chris
mr gaines
miss duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
this is feinstein
mrs fisher
this is giloram
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
ms hasson
mr hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr randhoff
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss clavichara
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
miss llamas
mr mansion
mr markey
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran ms markowski mr murphy mrs
murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
[Music]
mr peters mr portman mr reed mr risch
mr romney
miss rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott florida mr scott of south
carolina
this is shaheen
mr shelby
thanks buddy that's fine right here i'll
take it perfect
thank you
miss cinema
miss smith miss
kavanaugh
mr sullivan
mr chester mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
and holland mr warner
mr warnock ms warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
oh
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin blumenthal cardin coons
duckworth graham heinrich kelly
klobuchar lujan manchin marky
menendez merkley peters
reed rosen sanders cinema
tester warner warren whitehouse
ms collins i
senators voting in the negative
blackburn capitol cassidy cotton
crapo cruise ernst haggerty
hoeven hyde smith johnson
lummus moran murkowski rish
romney rounds scott of florida
scott of south carolina tillis
wicker mr wyden
i
[Music]
see
[Music]
you think
mr danes mr danes now
mr marshall mr marshall now
mr tubberville mr tubberville
[Music]
now
this is jill around this is jill around
i
mr kramer mr kramer
now
mrs fisher mrs fisher now
mr grassley mr grassley no
[Music]
mr sass mr sass now
miss smith's mrs smith
aye mrs shaheen mrs shaheen
aye
this house in assassin aye
hanhoff mr rainhof now
mr shots mr shots i
[Music]
mr casey mr casey i
mr leahy mr leahy
aye
mr blunt mr blunt no mr lee
mr lee no
this can't well miss cantwell i
mr kane mr kane i
mr timmy mr timmy
now
mr booker mr booker uh
mr braun mr braun no
mr rubio mr rubio no
mr murphy mr murphy i
mrs murray mrs murray aye
you
mr lankford mr lankford now
mr king mr king
this is feinstein mrs feinstein i
[Music]
okay
mr van hollen mr van hollen uh
[Music]
mr bennett mr bennett aye
mr paul mr paul now
mr hawley mr hawley no
no
mr schumer mr schumer
aye ms cortez masto was cortez masto
i
[Music]
mr burr mr bird no
miss hirono miss morono aye
um
mr warnock mr warnock
i
do
[Music]
mr brown mr brown eye
mr shelby mr shelby no
so
stop now i'm stabbing out i
[Music]
mr padilla mr padilla i
mr carper mr carper i
mr sullivan mr sullivan
no
[Music]
mr durbin mr durbin aye mr kennedy mr
kennedy
[Music]
now
mr barrasso mr barrasso now
uh
um
okay
mr assaf mr ostoff
i
mr then mr thun now
[Music]
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell no
mr portman mr portman
[Music]
okay
so
so
mr hickenlooper aye mr cornyn mr cornyn
here
this
[Music]
there
so
[Music]
mr boseman mr bozeman
[Music]
now
has every senator voted does any senator
was
wish to change his or her vote
if not the yeas are 52 the nays are 48.
the motion is agreed to
madam president the democratic whip
madam president um last week i told the
story
of a mother who received critical
support from an organization called
lifespan in chicago after her daughter
was
sexually assaulted by the mother's
husband
the services provided by lifespan were
paid for by the victims of crime act
voca this week i want to tell you
another story that is even more
troubling
but it dramatizes the need for us to act
today
this afternoon to resolve a problem
that is serious i'm going to use
the name sasha not the real name of the
woman involved
she was in chicago mother of three kids
and she was living with man who was
unpredictable
and dangerous he got so drunk that he
tried to kill her
not once but three times he tried
strangling her the first two times and
she ran away third time she passed out
when she woke up with the kids nearby
she knew that was it she couldn't take
it anymore
so she went to a hospital hoping to
get some help there she was scared to
death
she brought her kids with her because
she didn't want to
be around the man that did this to her
she heard about a group called harbor
house in chicago
harbor house is basically a domestic
violence survivors
center i would tell my colleagues in the
senate
if you have ever visited domestic
violence
survivor center and met with any of the
victims you'll never forget it
i swear you'll never forget it i can
remember the first time i met
with one of the victims in one of the
shelters
she was crying her eyes were red
and one eye was blackened
and she choked back to tears and told
her the story of what she'd lived
through
for some reason and i i'm not a
psychologist i can't explain it
she blamed herself and it happened so
often
what happens to these women who are the
victims of domestic violence and abuse
where do they go some of them
can't find anywhere to go and end up
dying as a result of it
what happens to their kids who witness
these acts of violence in the home
when moms getting strangled by this man
what happens to them well luckily
we care enough in america to do
something about it
through voca the victims fund we send
money to harbor house and lifespan and
other agencies and say
do your best help them put their lives
back together again
protect them well
i want to fast forward and tell you six
months after sasha's experience
things are much better she lives safely
in an apartment that's provided by this
agency
she still works with adult counselors
and youth counselors to get herself
and her kids through this and she knows
that she's not alone
these vocal funded advocates stepped
into her life at just the right moment
and
saved her life that may have saved the
lives of her children too
so when we cut back on funding for
whatever reason
we are jeopardizing the services that i
just described
that are so critical
with decreased vocal funding if we do
nothing today
with decreased vocal funding harbor
house will have to cut three of his
staffers including a legal advocate
adult counselor and youth counselor
exactly the
type of professionals that help sasha
and her family
the executive director said if voca is
cut imagine being sasha and having to go
through this alone
that's why you've got to pass this bill
that's why it's so critical
as i noted last week volca passed in
1984
to establish the crime victims fund we
can't even count the number of people
who've been helped over the years
three thousand applicants come through
my state attorney general's office in
illinois
and every state has a similar story to
tell
thousands of victims helped by service
providers
victims of domestic violence sexual
assault child abuse
trafficking and drunk driving
the crimes victims fund doesn't receive
a dime of taxpayers dollars
how about that what i just described for
you doesn't come out of the treasury
it funded through criminal fines
penalties forfeited bail bonds and
special assessments collected by the
federal government
historically most of the money comes
from criminal fines but in recent years
deposits have dropped off significantly
that's why we're here at this moment
they need help
and they need it now monetary
penalties from deferred prosecutions and
non-prosecuting issuing agreements
are currently deposited in the treasury
instead of the fund
as a result the shift has had a
devastating impact on the fund
that's why a bipartisan bicameral group
of members of congress
working with advocacy organizations have
come up with this vocal fix our bill
would stabilize the depleted fund
by redirecting monetary penalties from
deferred prosecutions and
non-prosecution agreements
to the victims and services providers
that need the help
the reduced deposits into the funds have
already had a devastating impact
victim assistance grants have been
reduced by more than 600 million dollars
in this fiscal year 600 million
nationwide
and more cuts are coming if we don't do
something today
like harbor house advocates across the
state across the country
are begging for help we don't have any
time to waste
every day that goes by we miss an
opportunity to help replenish the fund
and to put these services on the street
so far this year the fund has already
missed out on a total of nearly
550 million dollars in deposits that
could be helping these agencies
and we're not even halfway through the
years through the year
that's why it's imperative that we pass
this bill the house
already did it in march three months ago
bipartisan support here in the senate we
have a broad bipartisan coalition of 57
senators
37 democrats and 21 republicans we all
get it
we're all for crime victims but we've
been stopped
because of an objection on the floor
let's end this today
whatever the merits of any budgetary
argument for goodness sakes lives are at
stake here
unfortunately this objection about
moving forward was made last week and
probably will be made
again today it involves a senator
senator toomey's concern about a
budgetary
issue it's a complicated issue
about something called chimps for
goodness sakes which he can explain and
i'm sure he will
but after last week's argument on this i
went to the advocates
who were telling us that we should send
this money as quickly as we can and said
is he right is this design without his
amendment
so that this money will not go to the
people who need it
they said he's wrong this is not going
to happen
and here's their statement during four
remarks for the unanimous consent last
week it was represented the vocal fix
act
fails to correct certain structural
issues that prevent the funds from
reaching victims and their advocates
underlined the premise of this statement
that these structural issues impact the
distribution of vocal funds to survivors
and advocates
is not accurate this is from the actual
agencies themselves
while the use of chimps as budget
offsets continues to be a contentious
issue they said
the claim that appropriators hoard money
rather than releasing it to victim
service
providers is false inaccurate and false
in reality appropriators have
substantially decreased the size of the
budget offset
by releasing far more than the amount
required by this proposed
substitute and the proposed substitute
intends to restructure the entire
appropriations process is incredibly
controversial
in other words we're going to dive into
the deep end of the pool on
budget process and budget
rules and budget regulation
while people are literally drowning in
violence
victims of domestic abuse
for goodness sakes isn't there a better
time and place and a better
group to hold hostage it shouldn't be
these domestic violence victims i
yield at this point senator from rhode
island
thank you
senator from rhode island i won't speak
long but i wanted to
uh echo the comments of
our distinguished judiciary chairman
because i've had a similar
experience um as we were going through
covid i was hearing from our domestic
violence groups
in rhode island that two things were
happening at once
instances were going up people were
trapped together
very difficult to find sanctuary houses
to go to
and the experience of domestic violence
was soaring
and while that was going on the funding
coming in
to these agencies through voca was
declining now there's a pretty simple
well first we thank the rhode island
coalition against domestic violence
and sojourner house which provides
sanctuary services
and uh progreso latino which works in
this space in our latino
community for their great work there are
a lot of organizations in this space and
i
want to start by appreciating them the
problem
has nothing to do with domestic violence
or domestic violence victims as to the
money
the problem is that more and more of
these cases are resolved
by deferred prosecution and
non-prosecution agreements
but the funding for voca comes out of
criminal sentences criminal prosecutions
so because of that change in the way
these cases are treated
which is actually a good thing generally
the money is diverted
and as a result the crime victims fund
has reached its lowest level
in 10 years the victim assistance grants
in rhode island fell 50
50 cut in half from fiscal year 16 to 15
year 21
7.6 million dollars to 3.8
million dollars which means that many of
these local organizations that put their
heart and soul
into protecting these victims at the
worst time of their lives
have to deal with 50 cuts this is simple
it will allow monetary penalties in
those deferred prosecution
and non-prosecution agreements to flow
the same way they flow when traditional
prosecutions
take place this is endorsed across the
board this is as non-controversial as
you get
56 state and territorial attorneys
general
more than 1700 local tribal state
regional and national advocacy
government and law enforcement
organizations
just this year 545
million dollars has been lost to the
voca fund because we haven't corrected
this
so i would echo
uh my chairman's remarks and urge
uh my friend the senator from
pennsylvania to find another point of
leverage another fulcrum
for his efforts to solve unrelated
problems
but let this problem be solved
and let these victims be served
i yield the floor mr president
this is senator from illinois thanks to
the senator from rhode island
as if in legislative session i ask
unanimous consent the senate proceeded
to immediate consideration of h.r 1652
which was received from the house
and is at the desk further the bill be
considered right a third time and passed
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
is there objection mr president
senator from pennsylvania mr president
uh reserving the right to object
i i've got good news for my colleagues
from illinois
and rhode island and that is that
uh the modification that i'm suggesting
to the unanimous consent request offered
by the senator from illinois
is not complicated it's got nothing to
do with budget rules
in fact it's the simplest thing in the
world now the senator from illinois
wants to put more money and money from a
new source
into the crime victims fund
i completely agree i fully support it
i've i've liked this idea from the first
time i heard of it
and i've supported it but there's
something that's important to note here
the crime victims fund
is a federal government account and the
senator is
very determined that more money go into
that account so what do we disagree on
well it's very simple
the senator from illinois seems to be
equally determined
that there can be no requirement that
the money actually come
out of that account and go to crime
victims and they're advocates
that's the only thing that i want to do
differently
is to insist that money going into that
account
actually comes out and goes to the
victims of crimes
and their advocates now if my concern
that this money is not going to end up
going where it's
advertised to go is not valid then i
don't know why
my colleagues wouldn't agree to my very
narrow
amendment which by the way doesn't have
a thing to do with budget rules i don't
change i don't attempt
to change budget rules in this effort we
should change them but this isn't where
i'm trying to do it what i'm simply
trying to do
is make sure that the money that goes
into the account the increase too
actually goes to where it's supposed to
go which is the victims of crimes and
their advocates
so you have to ask yourself why would
somebody oppose
the proposal that this money actually be
required to go
to victims and their advocates why would
somebody oppose that
maybe it's because there's some other
place that some of this money is meant
to go
and that's that's at the heart of this
you see
under the ridiculous rules we operate
under
if the money doesn't end up going to
crime victims and they're advocates
then it frees up additional money to be
spent on whatever
anybody else wants to spend it on the
money that is withheld
from the people who are supposed to get
it crime victims and their advocates
creates the opportunity to spend more on
who knows what
now would anyone actually do this or is
this just a
theoretical construct that i've made up
well let's take a look at the recent
history
the fact is since 2000 in the year 2000
over 80 billion dollars that could have
been should have gone to crime victims
and their
advocates was intentionally withheld
so that more money could be spent in
other categories what this
chart shows is the amount of money year
in and year out it starts in 2000 you
see these low bars
well under a billion dollars
was actually allocated to crime victims
and therefore there was much more money
going into those accounts
much more money because you see how much
going into the account
isn't the only thing that matters what's
actually ultimately much more important
is how much comes out of the account and
goes to the crime and only when
i and some of my colleagues started
raising hell about this
the dishonesty of it the deception the
fact that crime victims and their
advocates weren't getting nearly
what they were supposed to be getting
only then this is the red line
represents when we started
doing this that's when the allocation
started to change
this represents the huge surge in funds
that we've been sending to crime victims
and their advocates
in recent years because some of us
were no longer willing to tolerate this
and we were raising cain about
what had been going on now what i'm
simply trying to do
is prevent us from going back to what
was routine around here what was in
standard operating procedures
which was to deceive people pretend that
money was going to end up going a crime
victims fund when everybody knew it
wasn't
now why would i be concerned that we
might be going back
in that direction well
i'll tell you why president biden has
been very instructive about this
in his budget that he released just
months ago
he actually specifies
that in his budget he wants money to be
diverted
from the crime victims fund which is
mentioned by name
and one other fund so that more money
can be spent on other purposes
this is my concern this isn't this isn't
some
thing that's been made up this is
president biden
in his budget asking us to go right back
to what we used to do
and so then when i come down here and i
suggest
one modification to the very
constructive idea that we add the
settlement money to the fund
and the modification is that the money
actually has to go to crime victims and
their advocates
that's subjected to people are insistent
that we not have a requirement that this
money actually be allocated
so someone might think that that's
pretty strong
body of evidence that suggests maybe
all of this money isn't going to end up
where it's supposed to go
therefore i ask that the senator modify
his request
to include my amendment which is at the
desk that if he considered and agreed to
the
bill as amended be considered right a
third time it passed
and that the motions to reconsider be
considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection this president
reserving the right to object
if you listen to this explanation
there's one thing missing and it's
critical
there's a suggestion that this money for
the crime victims funds
is being spent for another purpose you
never heard that did you
it said it could be maybe it will be
it might be but it hasn't been listen to
what they say
these people in the advocacy groups who
believe me are jealously watching every
penny
they want every dollar just as you do
and i do
and what do they say about your argument
the premise of your statement
that these structural issues impact the
distribution
of victims funds to survivors and
advocates
is not accurate goes on to say the claim
that appropriators
hoard the money rather than releasing it
to victim services
is false some very agencies receiving
the money
are they in on the deal senator i don't
think so
they're desperate for these funds and
without them they're going to have a
serious cut back in services
the proposed substitute intended to
restructure the entire appropriations
process
is incredibly controversial and you know
it and i know it as a member of the
appropriations committee
and yet you're tangling up this entire
appropriation
for the victims of crime victims of
domestic abuse
women who are seeking shelter and help
in hospital
care and trying to care for their
children and what they're going through
you want to hold back on the possibility
the possibility
somebody's going to spend this on
something else even though you have no
proof that it's been done
none and the people who are the
advocates for these groups are saying
to you what you're saying is inaccurate
and false
and you won't give it up i'd suggest
pick another target find some other
group to make your budget point of order
please don't take these people who are
in the most desperate situations in
their life
this is not the time of place to raise
this budget debate
i sincerely hope that you'll think about
them for a moment i object to your
modification
is there objection to the original
request so reserving the right to object
we this isn't a this is an amazing
argument the senator from illinois is
making
he's saying don't worry we would never
do
what the senator from pennsylvania is
suggesting might happen and which by the
way
always used to happen and which by the
way the president
is asking us to do we would never do it
ah
but i'll object to a requirement that
the money actually go
where we say it's going to go i think
that tells us
all we need to know and so i object
objection is heard
[Music]
mr president senator from florida
mr president has been a trying year for
our nation
thankfully the vaccine has brought so
much hope and a semblance of normalcy
back to the lives of many americans
as families and businesses in florida
across the u.s continue to work hard
to recover from the devastation of cover
19
travel is critical to get our economy
fully reopened
from the beginning of the pandemic i
encouraged everyone to wear a mask
as we learned more about this virus but
now the science is clear
that broad mask mandates aren't
necessary
unfortunately the cdc has decided to
buck the science when it comes to travel
and is still requiring face masks on
public transportation
we've all heard the stories of how this
mandate impacts families
a mother and her six children
traumatized by being kicked off a flight
after her two-year-old daughter refused
to wear a mask
a new jersey couple forced a deep plane
because their two-year-old wouldn't wear
a mask
a colorado mother and her family booted
off a flight over fears their
three-year-old son
who has a disability wouldn't wear a
mask
an orthodox jewish family kicked off a
flight because their 15 month old baby
was not wearing a mask you can't make
this stuff up
it's made traveling with children nearly
impossible
after a year of hardships and being
apart from loved ones these families
were denied the ability to reconnect
it's awful and unnecessary and i hear
stories all the time about
parents with young children decide i'm
not getting on an airplane because i
know i'll get kicked off
or i might get kicked off and to make
eyelines even more confusing you're
allowed to remove your mask to eat and
drink
so why is it okay and totally safe to
not have a mask while you've eaten
a snack but dangerous to be on mask any
other time
the cdc itself has been clear mask
mandates aren't needed
you don't have to wear a mask in a
restaurant you don't have to wear a mask
in a hotel
you don't have to wear a mask at a
school you don't have to wear a mask at
a stadium
so why is the cdc singling out airlines
and public transformation
it doesn't make any sense this isn't a
political argument in fact
during our commerce committee markup of
the surface transportation measure last
week
both democrats republicans expressed
frustration
at the continuation of the mass mandate
republican democrat governors and mayors
across the country
have followed the science and lifted
mass mandates
just like the federal government should
not be in the business of requiring
americans to turn over their vaccination
records
the federal government should not be
mandating citizen's wear mask on public
transportation
that's why i've introduced the stop
mandating additional requirements for
travel or smart act
which would revoke the federal
requirement for americans to wear a mask
on public transportation americans
should be free to make choices
they feel are in the best interest of
their own health and the health of their
loved ones
if someone wants to wear a mask they are
absolutely free to do so
but the government has no right to tell
them what to do if an airline or other
private company decides it wants to
implement a mass policy
so be it this does not prohibit them
from doing so
i've been clear private companies should
be able to make decisions
that they feel are appropriate for their
employees and their customers
and then their customer gets to make a
decision this builds pure common sense
i'm glad to be joined today by my
colleague from utah senator lee
and he'll be speaking after i ask for
the consent the science just
doesn't support keeping the mass mandate
in place we have to listen to the
science
and work together to move america
forward i know americans will do the
right things to stay safe
and i hope my colleagues join me in the
in passing this important bill
as given legislative session i ask
unanimous consent that the committee on
help
be discharged from further consideration
of s-2084
and the senate proceed to its immediate
consideration i ask unanimous consent
that the bill be considered read a third
time
and passed and the motion to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table
mr president objection mr president
senator from washington mr president
reserving the right to
object right now experts at the centers
for disease control and prevention
are continuing to update their mass
requirements based on
latest developments including
requirements related to travel
they need us to be reinforcing their
science-based work to keep people
safe not overruling it we cannot pretend
this pandemic
is over this virus is still spreading it
is still mutating
it is still costing lives and it is
still leaving survivors
with long-haul symptoms and the new
delta variant is more contagious
more likely to send people to the
hospital and already
in our country we've made great progress
on vaccinations but there are still
people
who are not vaccinated as well as people
who cannot yet
get vaccinated we know masks remain
a simple effective way to protect
everyone
especially in small crowded spaces
in an airplane on a bus or a train
getting rid of mask requirements for
travel before the
experts tell us it is safe to do so is
not going to get people to their
destinations any faster
and it is not going to end this pandemic
any faster instead
it will draw things out it will cost
time
and it will cost lives mr president to
get everyone
safely through this pandemic we need to
listen to the experts
and let them do their jobs therefore i
object
objection is heard mr president
senator from utah mr president i'd echo
the remarks presented my by my friend
and colleague the junior senator from
florida
i agree wholeheartedly with his analysis
i don't think it's i think it's
unfortunate that we missed this
opportunity
to enact meaningful change today change
that's backed up by science it was in
january of this year that the centers
for disease control
ordered the mandatory use of mass on
planes trains buses
and other modes of public transit of
every kind
everywhere across this country
if americans fail to comply with this
mandate they risk being fined or even
criminally prosecuted
six months later the coronavirus
continues with the cdc refusing
to recognize its own research that
the mandate is no longer defensible
it's now june the vaccine's been
available for months
covid cases are plummeting and the
country's anxious to return
to the way things once were the cdc has
even
said that vaccinated americans don't
have to wear masks
and can get their lives back to normal
more than 45 percent of americans are
now fully vaccinated
states are lifting their restrictions
and in restaurants stores and workplaces
across the country
it's no longer required mercifully to
wear a mask
if americans still want to wear one they
can make that decision for themselves
they're free to do so but the cdc's
requirement that vaccinated individuals
even vaccinated individuals
must wear mass on all forms of public
transit
now blatantly contradicts the agency's
own policies
and the agency's own scientific research
it needlessly promotes fear
and plays politics with the lives
of the american people not to mention
it's imposed
absurd expectations and serious
consequences
on children and families especially
families with children
trying to travel you see after the
january mandate the cdc
issued a corresponding mandate that
exempted
only children over the age of two in
keeping with their original mask wearing
guidance guidance that is among
the most stringent in the world and i
would add the most
unrealistic in the world when you
consider that they require it
up to and including children as young as
two years old
so what have been some of the results of
this guidance
parents have been kicked off and banned
from flights
if their small children refuse to wear a
mask
for parents of kids with disabilities
and many parents
of especially small children compliance
has been nearly impossible
we already know that children especially
young children
are unlikely to contribute to the spread
of the virus
what we do not know however is
what scientific studies if any at all
the cdc happens to be relying on
in reaching this guidance in reaching
the conclusions
underlying this guidance in fact several
of my colleagues and i sent a letter to
the agency with this very question
more than two months ago on april 22nd
2001
and now more than two months later we
have yet
to receive an answer it's a very simple
question
and we have yet to receive any shred any
semblance
any scintilla of an answer i find that
unacceptable
mr president if the cdc actually
believes its own research
then it should act like it and if it
believes in the vaccines the very
vaccines on which we have spent
billions of taxpayer dollars then it
should act consistently
and instill confidence in the american
people rather
than fear and with the vaccine
now free and widely available
americans should be able to weigh the
cost
of the options before them and choose
for themselves whether to receive the
vaccine whether wear a mask
or whether to take their own precautions
free of any mandates imposed by their
government
but if the federal government is going
to have a say
in whether or not there should be a
mandate
it should be up to congress the
sole branch of the federal government
empowered
to enact law and not coincidentally
the the branch elected by and held most
accountable to the people at the most
regular intervals
it should be up to this branch of
government the legislative branch
to enact such a mandate to the extent
that the cdc
issued this mandate it did so using
delegate
using authority delegated to it from
congress
we in congress did not pass the mass
mandate
and we do not have
to defer to those bureaucrats who did
the science mr president the science
shows that wearing masks
should not be federal law and we should
act accordingly
we should moreover give americans some
reason to want to be vaccinated
when there's light at the end of the
tunnel when they can see that there's
some tangible immediate benefit to them
getting vaccinated they're more likely
to do it if they can safely enter a
place of mass transit
without a mask if they choose to do so
many more people will choose to get
vaccinated
if we give them that benefit or if we at
least allow the operators of those modes
of transportation
to allow people to do that we can assert
our rightful authority and promote sound
science
and common sense by supporting
the bill introduced by my friend and
colleague senator scott of florida
we need this to pass the american people
have suffered through a very
very long coveted winter it's time for
them to be able to make their own
choices
that is what we do best as americans
because we believe in freedom
we also believe that whenever the
coercive power of government especially
the coercive power
of the federal government is exercised
it must do so with the authority
of congress we should never tacitly
acquiesce
to the authority of
overlords within a bureaucratic agency
who were elected by no one
and ultimately accountable only to
themselves
we are in charge here we make the law we
shouldn't blindly defer to anyone
certainly not the cdc when the cdc
ignores its own
science thank you mr president
president the senator from florida
mr mr president i want to thank my
colleague from utah uh for his comments
i want to thank his
continued commitment always to make sure
that we
congress handles everything we can we
don't defer constantly to
the executive branch and making
decisions that we should be making this
is a simple example
of why we should be making this decision
this is this is following the science
and i'm i'm actually shocked that my
colleague from the state of washington
does not want to follow silence science
uh i don't understand why my colleague
from the state of washington wants
government to be dictating things i mean
who wants
why do we want to dictate to americans
how they live lead their lives why does
she uh think that the government has has
why has government lifted mandates in
states all across the country but not
and why is the cdc is fine with every
place by public transportation
it just doesn't make any sense americans
will do the right thing
it's not our job to dictate to tell them
how to leave their lives
if someone wants to marry a mat a wear
mask so be it they should do it
but the government has no right to tell
them that they have to wear a mask
if an airline or another private company
decides wants to implement a mass policy
have at it we shouldn't prohibit them
from wanting to do that
but we should not be dictating this so
i'm disappointed that my colleague from
the state of washington didn't go along
but
but i think it's important for us to
always make sure we're doing the right
thing for the american public and right
now the right thing is
eliminate the mass mandate on public
transportation thank you mr president
[Music]
president senator from michigan
mr president uh i rise today in support
of two
critical nominations jen easterly's
nomination to be the director of the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency
commonly referred to as cisa within the
department of homeland security
as well as robin carnahan to be the
administrator of the general
services administration or gsa
mr president our country is under attack
nation state actors and criminal
organizations are relentlessly
targeting our government critical
infrastructure
and key industries to infiltrate
networks
steal information conduct espionage
and demand ransom payments these cyber
attacks pose a
serious threat to our national security
as we saw from the solar winds hacked
as well as the colonial pipeline and gbs
ransomware attacks
cyber criminals are constantly looking
to exploit
cyber security vulnerabilities and find
the weakest link we must be vigilant
about preventing these attacks and we
need a strong coordinated approach from
across the federal government to better
secure
america's networks that means the senate
needs to
confirm qualified cyber security
nominees so that they can get to work
immediately cisa is the lead domestic
agency for cyber security
in the federal government it's
responsible for ensuring that federal
departments
and agencies our private sector critical
infrastructure partners and the american
people
have the resources to detect to
withstand
and to respond to cyber attacks
gsa provides a wide range of support
agencies
across the government one of gsa's key
functions
is to provide funding and expertise to
help agencies
both modernize and secure their i t
systems and their networks we need
senate confirmed leadership at the top
of these critical agencies
and mr president we need it today ms
easterly has served for over
three decades in the federal government
and private sector
since 19 2017 ms easterly has led
operation center for morgan stanley's
cyber defense strategy
she was also a critical member of the
cyber solarium commission
which has made 80 recommendations for
cyber deterrence
25 of which already have become law
prior to joining the private sector ms
easterly served as the special assistant
to the president
and senior director for
counter-terrorism the deputy for
counter-terrorism at the national
security agency and was instrumental in
the design and creation
of the u.s cyber command on top of all
of these incredible accomplishments
this easterly is a two-time recipient of
the bronze star
and retired from the us army after more
than 20 years of service and
intelligence and cyber
operations ms easterly is more than
qualified for this position
and this body needs to confirm her
nomination today
to lead sissa every day every day that
this body delays
confirming critical leaders like miss
easterly and ms carnahan
leaves our federal system and our nation
vulnerable
to cyber attacks we have already seen
the damage and the chaos
from these attacks the colonial pipeline
attack disrupted the lives of millions
of americans created fuel shortages and
saddled customers with
high gas prices for weeks the next
major breach could be even worse
i urge my colleagues to join me in
supporting ms easterly's nomination to
lead sysa
and to take on the vital mission of
strengthening our defenses and
fighting back against the persistent
cyber attacks that threaten
our nation each and every day
cyber security and strengthening our
federal networks
are not partisan issues cyber attacks
put each and every one of us at risk
and i would hope my colleagues will
allow these nominees to be confirmed
today
so they can keep us safe and with that
mr president i ask unanimous consent
that notwithstanding rule 22
the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration
of calendar number 176 john
jen easterly of new york to be the
director
of the cyber security and infrastructure
security agency
department of homeland security and the
senate vote on the nomination
without intervening action or debate
is there objection mr president
senator from florida reserving the right
to object
i want to make one thing very clear i'm
here today to ensure accountability to
the american people
i voted to support miss easterly's
confirmation committee last week
and if senator schumer filed for cloture
like he has done for dozens of other
nominees
this year i would vote to support her
confirmation here on the center floor
this isn't about miss easterly this is
about this isn't about cyber security
remember we just unanimously confirmed
the national cyber director just last
week
i'm here today because families in my
state of florida and across our nation
deserve
accountability and president biden has
shown a total lack of accountability
when it comes to addressing the border
crisis that's why i announced last month
that i would be holding all the prison
rights nominees for the department of
homeland security from being approved
through
our expedited process until he and vice
president harris visit the border
and they see for themselves a crisis
that their failed policies of open
borders
and amnesty have created i understand
the white house just
announced that vice president harris
will be visiting the border later this
week
i hope that's true the administration
has made a lot of promises that they
haven't kept
like not raising taxes reopening schools
quickly being tough on communist china
the list goes on and on
trust me i'm glad the vice president
seems to be taking my advice and finally
listen to the american listening to the
american people
i truly hope that she gets down to the
border to see the crisis firsthand
that her administration and their failed
policies have created hope she meets
with the national border patrol council
here exact from them what our brave cb
cbp agents are going through every day
to keep us safe
hope she meets with border community
sheriffs who are responsible for keeping
our family safe
hope she meets with ice and cbp section
sheeps
so she can hear first hand impacted on
them
i hope she takes an aerial tour like i
did and sees the gaps in the wall
i hope she sees where the lights and
cameras are sitting powerless
without electricity unable to be used to
monitor our border
i hope she meets with families who have
been the victims of trafficking and
here's the horrific stories
they have what they've been through
because of this crisis hope she visits
border communities
they've been put in a position to house
and care for the historic number of
people
illegally crossing our border she talks
with families who have tragically lost
loved ones from the massive amounts of
fentanyl that the cartels are moving
across our border
up she talks to the ranchers impacted by
people illegally crossing their lands
more than anything i hope this isn't a
political stunt if she truly goes to see
this crisis
i'm gonna lift all my holds of dhs
political nominees
it's that simple what's happening at the
border is a crisis
there's simply no other word for it it's
been three months since i traveled to
the southern border to see exactly
how president biden's open borders and
amnesty policies
are weak are wrecking havoc i took i
took a tour with governor ducey
he did an arrow tour what do you see is
a wall and then all of a sudden these
openings
they just didn't they intentionally
didn't put up the gates
i remember my colleagues were saying oh
we don't all need the wall we have we
can have lights and cameras so that
they can monitor from someplace else
they're out there they're just not
hooked up to electricity
intentionally i mean you can't make this
stuff up
it's been three months sent made clear
that president biden and vice president
harris
need to get to the border and see the
crisis that their administration has
created
it's been three months since they
pledged to visit the border
since since then as you all know you
look at all the numbers apprehensions
at our southern border are at a record
high more than 180
000 illegal aliens tried to cross our
southern border last month and were
apprehended
the highest in 21 years this is a crisis
it threatens our national security and
the safety of american families
and we don't know how many people we
didn't apprehend president biden's
immigration policies are putting
unaccompanied minors at risk of human
trafficking
violence sexual abuse and separation for
their families
they're leading to an alarming increase
in human trafficking and drug smuggling
by cartels the fbi director ray said
this month there's no question that
cartel activity from mexico is spilling
over into the united states
we're seeing it here in florida i talked
to sheriffs what they're telling me is
unbelievable amounts of fentanyl are
coming across the border and getting
into our state
putting florida families in danger i was
down i was down in one
uh one lab and they're telling me that
uh two people died that week
uh from fentanyl but instead of securing
the border and finishing wall
construction projects
president biden is terminating all the
wall projects what why would you be
doing this
the inaction by president biden the vice
president harris is
inexcusable i don't know what they're
waiting for why can't they acknowledge
that a secure border is the best thing
for our nation if you talk to people
around this country they want a secure
border
why can't they stand up against the
radical left to say that open borders
are dangerous
to american families two weeks ago the
vice president went to guatemala in
mexico
she while she was there she was asked by
lester holt when she was going to go to
the border and she
laughed i mean this is not a laughing
matter
i mean this is this is a crisis and
people are dying because of this crisis
should make all of us furious people are
dying
children are being exploited and they're
being abandoned in the desert
earlier this year two ecuadorian
children two little girls three
and five years old were dropped over a
14 uh foot section of the border wall we
all saw the pictures
they were abandoned there in the middle
of the night two innocent little girls
just three and five years old
can you imagine how terrified they were
i mean i think of my daughters i think
my grandchildren
we all do we all think how think of how
would how would our family deal with
that
it just it makes it just breaks your
heart the vice president claims the vice
president's trip
uh was down to guatemala mexico was was
to
talk about the root cause of immigration
i don't believe that
the vice president's trip wasn't any
more than a poorly executed political
stunt
president biden vice president here need
to stop avoiding the crisis
stop laughing off this threat get to the
border take real steps
and as i said once they actually go to
the border and actually see the crisis
i'm going to lift my holds
this is all to make sure they go to the
border but as long as they refuse to
help those risking their lives every day
to keep us safe as long as they refuse
to visit the border
and put an end to the humanitarian
crisis that they created
i'm going to keep my holds on those two
those two little girls
and all the all the people that have
been trafficked they deserve better
the millions of immigrants in our
country going through a legal process
they deserve
better our border patrol agents they
deserve better
all american families deserve better
therefore i object
the objection is heard
senator from michigan mr president i'd
like to discuss
ms carnahan's qualifications further
before
asking for consent on her confirmation
ms carnahan has an extensive career
spanning
federal and state government as well as
the private sector
during the obama administration she
founded and led the state and local
practice
at 18 f a technology consulting firm
within or consultancy within
gsa in this role ms carnahan worked with
state and local government agencies to
improve and modernize their
their digital services prior to her
tenure at 18f ms carnahan served as
missouri's secretary of state
where she focused on modernizing i.t
infrastructure to
improve service for hundreds of
thousands of customers
ms carnahan is a nationally recognized
government technology leader
and in 2017 was named one of the federal
government's
top women in tech i urge my colleagues
to join me in supporting ms carnahan's
nomination to lead
gsa from modernizing and securing
federal networks to
strengthening supply chain security gsa
plays a critical role in bolstering
our national security so with that mr
president i ask unanimous consent that
notwithstanding rule 22
the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of the following
nomination calendar 175
is there objection
without objection the clerk will report
general services administration
robin carnahan of missouri to be
administrator
mr president i asked consent that the
senate vote on the nomination without
interfeing
action or debate and if confirmed the
motion to reconsider
be considered made and laid upon the
table all without intervening action or
debate
that no further motions be in order to
the nomination
that any statements related to the
nomination be printed in the record
that the president be immediately
notified of the senate's
action the question is on the nomination
all those in favor say aye aye all
opposed no
eyes appear to have it guys do have it
the nomination is confirmed
mr president senator from texas
mr president after months of unnecessary
hand-wringing
vice president harris has finally
announced that she intends to visit
the u.s mexico border she was
as you were called tapped by the
president to lead the efforts to stem
the current humanitarian crisis back in
march
but three months in she spent more time
trying to figure out
how to support central american
countries and how to help
american law enforcement and community
leaders in texas
in the absence of any action from the
administration in fact
any acknowledgement of the crisis at all
the humanitarian crisis has got nothing
but worse
in march the first month of her heading
up the administration's response
there were 173 000 migrants
that crossed our southern border then in
april the number
went up to 178 000 and in may
180 000 migrants
we're now on track to see the highest
number of totally early border crossings
in
two decades according to the secretary
of homeland con
security mr mayorkas
at the center of this crisis are
unaccompanied children
who are brought to this country by
cartels
and human smugglers we know that the
migrant children endure a long and
dangerous journey
to our border often arriving
malnourished
abused and in critical health
some of the young girls even arrive
pregnant and we know that many of them
have been sexually assaulted
in route by these human smugglers who
care
nothing for their welfare all they care
about
is the cold hard dollar i've talked to
a number of these children and heard
them retell their horrific stories about
their journey
from their home to our border
since january since the time that
president biden and vice president
harris were inaugurated
more than 65 000 unaccompanied children
have entered our country
with no parent and no adult guardian
an absolutely devastating figure
these children are then placed with
spunk sponsors
in the interior of the united states
sometimes a family member
sometimes a complete stranger
30 days after these children are placed
with their
american-based sponsor not necessarily
even american citizen
a full 20 percent of them don't respond
to a phone call
or a wellness check when a person
associated with the us government knocks
on the door
and we have no idea what happens to
these children once they're lost
to the system the border patrol's rio
grande valley sector is the
epicenter of this human crisis between
october and
and april that's where nearly half of
all unaccompanied children were
encountered in the three months since
vice president the vice president has
been in charge
of this crisis i've visited the rio
grande valley sector
twice i've spoken with law enforcement
elected officials non-governmental
organizations that try to be of
assistance to the migrants while they're
in the country
and a long list of other other people
who are trying to do everything in their
power to manage
this overwhelming number of
humanity coming across our border
on friday president harris won't get to
speak with these men and women
why is that well she'll be more than a
thousand miles away
down the border from the border patrol
sector experiencing the worst of this
crisis
i know they're probably folks who are
not from texas who think that the whole
border
is uh exactly the same but that's not
true
i had the chance to travel to tucson
with senator cinema the senator from
arizona and
i got a chance to observe how different
the border is in the tucson sector
from the rio grande valley which he
traveled with me to see
after we left tucson but since
october the rio grande valley sector has
encountered
nearly three times as many unaccompanied
children
as the el paso sector and more than
seven times more
family units the situation along the
entirety of the u.s border is
challenging to be
sure and el paso has suffered
during the crisis too no doubt law
enforcement
non-governmental organizations and
community leaders in every border
sector are struggling to manage the
massive surge
of migrants when asked why she hadn't
visited the border yet
the vice president said she wasn't
interested in
grand gestures yet here she is
planning a trip in a way that reflects
again she doesn't really fully
comprehend
the magnitude of the crisis and where
it's
where it really exists on steroids
which is the rio grande valley it's not
even fair to say that she's a daylight
and a dollar
short she's nearly a hundred days late
and a thousand miles
short by ignoring the rio grande valley
the busiest border patrol sector along
the u.s
texas mexico border the vice president
is shifting the focus away from the most
serious
problems of the crisis that she's failed
to solve or even contribute any
constructive ideas to
it won't surprise you to know that
during my time in the senate because my
state does have a 1200 mile common
border with mexico
i've spent a lot of time listening to
and learning from folks
who live and work along our border
our border is a beautiful part of our
state rich
in a unique culture and a rich sense of
humor
community that you can't find in many
parts of the country
through no fault of their own these
border communities are being overwhelmed
by the sheer number of migrants crossing
the border
and the local leaders are beyond
frustration with the failures of the
federal government to live up to its
obligation to provide security along
an international border the president
vice president have
i have to acknowledge verbally encourage
migrants not to come to the united
states
but those words mean nothing they're
hollow rhetoric
indeed when somebody can simply pick up
the phone
and call a family member in the united
states or watch
the evening news and see how easy it is
to make your way across the border
not to mention the fact that the human
smugglers the cartels
who charge thousands of dollars per head
are whispering in their ears
saying we can get you across the border
if you just pay us
our fee the reality of the situation is
we're
nearing a breaking point and the vice
president and president could see that
if they are only willing to join me and
others who would be more than happy to
host them
by visiting the rio grande valley
the administration has wasted valuable
time that could have been spent
addressing the crisis
this is a a crisis in policy this is not
where building an additional physical
barrier would stop
many of these migrants some of that
would and the border patrol said it has
a part to play
but the truth is many of these migrants
are turning themselves over
to law enforcement authorities they're
not running away because they've figured
out
the gaps in our law better than we have
the administration has wasted valuable
time that could have been
spent addressing this crisis and instead
it's just gotten worse
now the question is what are they going
to do about it
if they're looking for ideas i'm happy
to offer a suggestion
there's already a grassroots plan out
there that's built from the bottom up
by senators and congressmen most
familiar with this crisis
last month senator cinema the senator
from arizona and i introduced the
bipartisan border solutions act
a straightforward common sense way to
address this crisis
we've been proud to work with two house
members the chair presiding officer and
knows
congressman cuellar from laredo texas
along with tony gonzalez who represents
one of the biggest
congressional districts contiguous to
the u.s mexico border and they are our
co-sponsors
in the house so a bipartisan bicameral
bill to address the very crisis
that vice president harris and president
biden have been trying to avoid
learning more about at least until now
this legislation has support as i said
of members of both parties and in both
chambers
as well as a diverse range of
well-respected
organizations the u.s hispanic chamber
of commerce
the national border patrol council the
national immigration forum
and more than a dozen other
organizations support this legislation
i'd be more than happy to sit down with
the president and vice president to
discuss our bill
which includes the input of leaders who
are dealing with the brunt of the crisis
along the border if the administration
truly wants to address this crisis
they need to get serious about how to do
so and a photo op
simply will not get the job done the
vice president
i think would be well served and we'd be
serving
the people of this country well if she
would visit the rio grande valley
and listen to the law enforcement
elected officials and
ngos and other men and women who are
doing their best to try to deal with
this crisis
without much help from the
administration
mr president the administration has
wasted too much time already
now is not the time for another empty
gesture
mr president i yield the floor
[Music]
mr president senator from maryland
uh thank you mr president i rise this
afternoon in support of the nomination
of u.s magistrate judge deborah boardman
to be a united states district judge for
the district of maryland
judge boardman was favorably reported by
the judiciary committee on june 10th
i had recommended judge boardman along
with senator van hollen
to president biden and i strongly
support
her nomination judge boardman was
nominated
to fill the future vacancy created when
judge richard bennett
appointed by president bush in 2003
announced his intentions to take senior
status upon the confirmation
of his successor president biden
nominated judge boardman for this
position on march 30th
and the judiciary committee held her
confirmation hearing on may the 12th
shortly after the november 2020
presidential election
i worked with senator van hollen to
establish a
judicial selection committee in maryland
we used an open application process with
public advertisement and communicated
closely
with the state local and specialty bar
associations
in maryland in particular we sought out
highly qualified
and diverse applicant pull our committee
interviewed
everyone who submitted an application
which involved
several dozen interviews senator vin
holland and i
personally interviewed several finalists
before making our recommendations
to the white house i strongly agree with
president biden's request that senators
consider
nominating individuals whose legal
experiences have been historically
underrepresented on the federal bench
including those
who are public defenders civil rights
and legal aid attorneys
and those who represent americans in
every
walk of life judge boardman
fits that request judge deborah boardman
was born in silver spring
raised in frederick and lives in
baltimore she received a ba
from villanova university after
graduating from college she accepted a
fulbright scholarship to study
in amman jordan she received her jd
from the university of virginia school
law after law school she clerked for a
federal judge
on the eastern district of virginia
known as the rocket dirk a docket
for the speed of its caseload judge
boardman brings tremendous experience to
the fed
to the courtroom as a sitting u.s
magistrate judge in maryland
since 2019 which is the same federal
judicial
district in which she would become a
district judge
if confirmed by the senate she already
handles a heavy caseload
in our federal court as a magistrate
judge judge boardman presides over civil
cases by consent
of the parties resolves civil discovery
disputes
conducts settlement conferences and
presides over preliminary criminal
proceedings
additionally she administers the
district of maryland's
social security appeals docket
in civil cases before her by consent of
the parties judge boardman rules on
motions to dismiss
resolves the discovery disputes decides
whether a case should proceed to trial
and presides over bench and jury trials
these cases have involved claims of
unemployment discrimination
in violation of title vii of the civil
rights act of 1964
the americans with disabilities act the
rehabilitation
act claims under 42 usc 1983
the fair labor standards act the debt
fair debt collection practices act
qualified and sovereign immunity
defenses and state law claims stemming
from
contract disputes and personal injury
as you can see mr president she has
broad experience
in regards to her tenure as a magistrate
judge
she has previously served as the first
assistant federal public defender of
maryland
during her 11-year tenure with the
federal defender's office judge boardman
represented individuals
in both the greenbelt and baltimore
courthouses that were charged with
federal crimes
she also has experience in private
practice as she served as a litigation
associate
at hogan and lawless formerly known as
hogan and hartson
in washington dc from 2001 to 2008.
during those years judge boardman worked
exclusively
on civil matters she has experience both
on the civil side and criminal side
she represented a wide range of
corporate and individual clients in
state and federal courts
specifically she counseled insurance
companies universities healthcare and
pharmaceutical companies
among others in business and contract
dispute
as a fifth year associate the firms
selected judge boardman
to serve as the senior pro bono
associate in his nationally recognized
pro bono department
she managed the firm's largest pro bono
cases
full time and appeared in federal and
state courts
as a lead attorney in several of these
pro bono cases
she tried a wrongful eviction action
before d.c jury
she was lead counsel in a three-day
evidentiary hearing on habeas corpus
petitions
in the circuit court for the city of
norfolk she argued numerous discovery
motions before the u.s magistrate judge
in the district
court for the district of columbia in an
unemployment discrimination
class action lawsuit
madam president the american bar
association
standing committee on the federal
judiciary
gave judge boermann its highest
unanimous well qualified recommendation
after evaluating her integrity
professional competence
and judicial temperament as judge
boardman said at her confirmation
hearing
she's the daughter of the american
revolution on her father's side
and a first generation american
palestinian descent
on her mother's side her father was born
in new york
and was drafted to serve in the u.s army
in the vietnam war
and then went on to be a successful
businessman
her mother was born in ramallah a
palestinian city in the west bank
she emigrated to the united states in
the 1950s
with her parents and eight brothers and
sisters when she was just 13 years of
age
she spoke no english and when she began
attending public school in
suburban maryland uh she then learned of
course english
and went on to be a successful career as
a beautician
judge boardman has testified that her
parents taught her the value of hard
work
the importance of education the value of
family
and the need to be generous to those who
are less fortunate in life
in my discussions the meeting with judge
boardman i have some impressions that
stand out
from her as a person she is fully
committed to public service through her
diverse professional career as a lawyer
law firm partner public defender and now
u.s magistrate judge she regards being a
sitting judge as the ultimate
and highest calling of public service in
the legal profession
she wants to inspire the public's
confidence in the judiciary
and to hear parties concerns
compassionately while upholding her duty
to fairly apply
the law now as a u.s magistrate judge
judge worman has told me she understands
the absolute importance of adjudicating
disputes
neutrally and fairly she surely has the
temperament for this position she has
told me that she is
naturally curious and tries to avoid
making assumptions
judge boardman shared with me that her
internal compass directed her
towards service judges are first and
foremost public servants but they hold
certain powers over individual lives she
understands that in her view
a district court judgeship is much more
than an achievement it's a serious
public responsibility which requires a
judge to put the
public first as they uphold the rule
of law numerous individuals wrote to me
on judge boardman's behalf including
several sitting judges law firm
associates and colleagues
from her service in the public
defender's office they
unanimously praised judge boermann's
courtroom skills as a litigator
in particular praising her courtroom
presence sharp legal and analytical
skills
in both written and oral advocacy and
her high level of professionalism
excellent temperament and unfailing
courtesy to all parties
as a person i repeatedly been told by
those that know her well that judge
boardman is the best kind of person to
be a judge
she is smart patient kind
and tough when she needs to be she's a
hard worker
and she sees all sides of an argument
and is always fair and professional
in her treatment of others
i was delighted to recommend the
nomination to judge boardman to
president biden along with senator van
hollen
judicial nominees must meet the highest
standard of integrity
competency and temperament judge
boardman will safeguard the rights
of all marylanders and all americans
uphold the constitution
and rule of law and faithfully follow
the judicial oath
to do equal right to the poor and to the
rich
i am confident that judge boardman will
serve the people
of maryland very well once she is
confirmed
madam president i urge my colleagues to
vote for the confirmation of judge
boardman who is an outstanding judicial
nominee for maryland she's already a
sitting united states magistrate judge
on the u.s district court for district
maryland
where she has served the district judges
i look forward to her continued public
service to maryland
and to the nation with that mr president
i yield the floor
madam president the senator from
oklahoma
thank you madam president i as
consent this week was in mourning
business for such time as i shall
consume
without objection all right uh madam
president last
year the federal communications
commission
approved an application by legato
networks to
repurpose federal spectrum in a way
that will drastically interfere with gps
in satellite communications
this is a big deal there are so many
people who
understand this situation there's a list
of
companies behind us that grows every day
almost every company in america that you
know
of or have heard of his name is on this
list
the decision that was made was
threatened gps and satellite
communications reliability for millions
of americans who
who depend on it the liability of gps
and satellite communications is
necessary
for safety of life operations
national security and economic activity
and i'm
i'm going to pause here for a minute to
drive home
what this actually means for every
american
because people don't know this they
don't know how important gps is
and yet there's not an american i can
think of by description
who isn't using it every day
so if something happens to it there's a
serious problems
here are some of the day-to-day
activities that would be difficult
when experiencing gps interference from
legato
a big one using your credit card or your
debit card
uh when you're making a purchase or
using an atm
our financial systems rely on gps timing
in order to work another one making a
phone call
a cell phone networks rely on gps
synchronized cell towers so calls can be
passed seamlessly if they experience
interference you could
drop be dropped when moving from one
tower to another
another one of the most people are not
aware of
and don't expect is energy
whether that is filling up your tank
with with gas at the pump
or electrical grids to light our homes
we rely on gps timing to safely operate
underground pipelines and our electric
electricity
grid uh farmers and ranchers and it's
something a lot of people are not aware
of
but they depend on gps in in satellite
communications
when planting crops applying fertilizer
during harvest operation to move large
and critical machinery
with precision working out a lot of
people don't
i don't do as much you do they say
one-fifth of the population 20 percent
of the population
or of all americans use fitness trackers
smart watch or the majority of used gps
to count steps and with an attractive
distance
we all know that we see it there every
day they're all using it and they depend
on
what they depend on gps taking
a flight at occasion i've been
involved in aviation for uh over 70
years now and
had an occasion with three friends to uh
fly around the world in 1991
using gps and at that time it may be the
first the the equipment that i use
was a trembo tnl2000
trimble is one of the big gps companies
i was using with the tnl2000 at that
time
that may have been worth checking to see
the first time that that's been used
for private aviation flying all the way
around the world again that's
the gps and that was 1991.
and things driving around right now each
day countless americans rely on google
maps
maze ways apple maps
and any other navigation system
to get them from point a to point b and
while
no one hopes whoever need a fire truck
or ambulance or
the 911 operators the ems
gps they use gps on a daily basis
so there's more weather forecasting the
movement of goods
on our highways surveying maritime
harbors
channels and everything else the list
goes on and on
now how do we know that legato will
cause interference the fcc
told us when they approved the the gotta
order and i would read that
now because i think people need to
understand
i guess we'd say we were warned the fcc
said
in their their document that was the
document they used on their
their approval order they said quote
legato
shall expeditiously repair or replace as
needed
any u.s government gps devices
that experience or are likely to
experience harmful interference from
legato's operations
unquote that's a quote that's what they
said that's what fcc
said at that time over 21 organizations
and companies and industries have filed
petitions
for reconsideration after the order was
released
documenting the damage that they face
from the
legato interference that this this thing
right out
behind me is now up to 82
it was 78 this morning and that the list
goes on
and on you can hardly think of a
corporation in america
that isn't on this list and so it's
it's something that is a very serious
problem in widespread
there's one way to put the interference
into perspective
because gps signals travel from
satellite in space
by the time those signals get to earth's
surface
they are low power because
the fcc order allows legato to repurpose
spectrum to operate a terrestrial
based network legato signals on earth's
surface will be much more powerful
than gps causing substantial
and harmful interference and while the
fcc
required legato to repair damage to
federal agencies
that result from the interference
congressional action is needed because
the sense of strategy to combat this
surge in gun
violence president acknowledging that
there has been a spike in violent crime
in many big cities particularly what he
says is